[MUSIC PLAYING]
KURTIS VAN GENT: So
today we're going
to talk about creating a
database with Cloud SQL.
So that's going to be
our first step is we're
going to launch Cloud SQL.
Then we're going to move on
to setting up Kubernetes.
We're going to be using
GKE to launch our cluster.
And then, finally, we're
going to deploy an application
on that, and we're going
to examine the fault
tolerance of the application.
So we're going to take a look
at what makes it resilient,
some couple of
ways it can crash,
and how we can get it back
up as quickly as possible.
So my name is Kurtis Van Gent.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer for Google.
I work on Cloud SQL.
So one of the things
I do is try and make
Cloud SQL more friendly
for developers.
That's pretty much my whole job.
It's what I work on every day.
But I want to hear a
little bit about you guys.
So I know we still have some
people coming in the room,
but I'm just going to
go through each one,
and let's try and
get a show of hands.
So how many people
in here consider
themselves a developer?
Go ahead and raise your hand.
All right, we've got a
ton of developers in here.
That's great.
So how many people consider
themselves system admins?
OK.
A few hands, not very many.
How many of you guys
consider yourselves DevOps
practitioners?
OK.
Great.
Quite a few hands.
And how many of yourselves
consider yourselves DVAs?
A few hands.
How many of yourselves
don't really
want to consider yourselves
a DVA but you do anyway?
OK, there's like five or six.
Great.
That's usually how
these talks go.
OK, sweet.
Well, that gives us a
good starting point.
I'm going to try and introduce
some of the terminology,
so that if you haven't
used Kubernetes before,
you'll still be able to
follow along and keep up.
But we are going to skip
over some of the basics,
like how containers work.
This is a 300 level
course, after all.
I don't want to bore
everybody else too badly.
So now for a really
personal question--
do you guys use tabs or spaces?
Right?
So why don't we get a
show of hands for tabs?
OK, there's like a little over
half, a little under half,
maybe, a little under half.
OK.
How about spaces?
It's like 40% of each,
and 20% just don't care.
So today our
application is going
to be talking about launching--
the application we're
going to be launching
is going to be a voting
system for tabs versus spaces.
And so as you guys obviously
care very deeply about this,
we have some specific
goals of this.
We need to be able to
handle high traffic.
So when everybody
gets on their phones,
the application has
to be able to respond.
I don't want anybody
calling, hey, voter fraud.
I couldn't get my
vote for spaces in,
so this doesn't count.
It needs low maintenance.
So I'm going to be
up here talking.
I don't really have
time to monitor it.
So I need to make sure that
it's taking care of itself,
and it doesn't really require
a lot of hands-on for me.
And then I need it to be
almost always available.
If it goes down, you guys
are going to cry foul.
You're going to say the
results aren't fair.
And we need to make sure
that that doesn't happen.
So with that in mind,
let's take a look at what
we have for our database.
We're going to be starting
with Cloud SQL today.
So if you haven't
used Cloud SQL before,
there are some
really great benefits
to using a managed database.
The first of all is you
don't have to be DBA anymore.
You can just let
Google take care of it.
So it's fully managed.
We have PostgreSQL
and MySQL instances.
And you can run your
instances anywhere.
So you can deploy to
any region in the world
that we support, and
it'll work great.
You also get some
advantages like performance
and scalability.
So Cloud SQL is
optimized for RVMs.
So we take MySQL.
We take PostgreSQL.
We tune all the flags so that
works as best as possible
running on our hardware.
And you can also change
the size of the hardware
with a few clicks of the button.
So you can go from
one instance to 64.
If you write an app and it
becomes popular overnight,
you can scale your database up.
If you are running a lot
of high volume queries,
and you need a little
bit of extra RAM instead
of a little extra CPU power so
that those have enough space
to optimize, those options
are all available for you.
And then last but not least, you
get reliability and security.
So we've got 99.95 SLOs
around availability.
And you also get advantages like
the high availability options,
which we're going to
talk about in a second.
So high availability is
one of my favorite features
of Cloud SQL.
Specifically for Postgres,
we have a really unique way
of implementing it.
How it works is we have--
so in GCP, if you guys aren't
aware, we have regions.
And then within those we
have fault tolerance zones.
So zones are-- an
entire zone can go down
and nothing will
affect all the others.
They're completely separate.
If you spin up a
Cloud SQL instance,
you start with a
primary instance.
You're going to click one button
to enable high availability,
and you're going to
get a standby instance
in a second region.
So that's going to work
using our persistent disk.
That's a service we offer.
It does storage level
synchronous replication.
So as soon as your database
writes in one zone,
it'll automatically
sync to the next zone.
The advantage of
this is you don't
have to worry about
any replication lag
or anything like that.
As long as your database
accepted the transaction,
the backup is going
to have it as well.
So because of this, we have
the replica waiting for you.
All we have to do is say,
promote that one to master.
Failovers are very, very quick--
typically take less
than 60 seconds.
If you guys want
to check it out,
we have a demo on the floor
today, High Availability
with Cloud SQL.
And the averages are
somewhere around 35 seconds.
So connecting to Cloud
SQL-- when your database is
in a cloud, there's always
some interesting problems
you have to run into.
So Cloud SQL has a few
different connection options.
You pretty much have to choose
between two different groups.
You have to choose
one connection path.
And you have to choose
a way to authenticate.
So when it comes to
connecting with Cloud SQL,
we have public IP.
So that's an IP that's
open on the internet.
You will have to pair
it with authentication.
By default, it's closed off.
You can only access it if
you're an approved user.
And we'll go through how
to do that in a second.
And we also have private IP.
So private networking
is available
if you're using
our VPC technology.
That allows you to create
a cluster market as VPC,
and then all of the
things inside that VPC
talk directly to each other.
They don't have to go
outside of Google's network.
Everything stays private.
Everything stays secure.
With authentication, you've got
a couple of different options.
Most of these are
used with public IP,
but they definitely can
be used with private IP
if you want that extra security.
The first option is
white listing IP.
You can create a list of IPs
that are allowed to connect.
This is an OK option.
But if any of you guys are
familiar with security,
there's a few disadvantages
to that, so we offer
some other options as well.
You can have an approved
SSL certificate.
So you can click a button,
get an SSL certificate,
distribute the client
key to your application,
and link up with it.
Or you can use my favorite way,
which is the Cloud SQL proxy.
The Cloud SQL proxy has
a bunch of advantages,
including security.
And it gives you control
with an IEM account.
So you can actually
create an IEM account,
say you're allowed to
talk to this database.
And then, if for some reason you
decide that application should
no longer have access
to this database,
you can either remove
that privilege,
or you can just delete
that account entirely.
And you'll note,
they will no longer
be able to access your
database, which is great.
So today we're going to be using
the Cloud SQL proxy to connect.
So like I mentioned,
it's really convenient.
You don't have to worry
about white listing.
about managing SSL keys.
All you do is create
the IEM account,
apply it to a service account,
and the service account
will connect on behalf
of your application.
This makes it really
quick, really secure.
This proxy is also open sourced.
It's available on GitHub.
So if for some reason
there's something
with the proxy that's not
working for you right,
you can download the code.
You can look at
it yourself, make
whatever edits you need to.
OK.
So with all that in
mind, let's go ahead
and go through the demo.
We're going to take a second
and connect to Cloud SQL.
So if we could
switch to the laptop.
All right, so here I've got
a project created for us.
We're just going
to open this up.
Go to the Cloud SQL page.
I've created a backup, just
in case the demo gods aren't
happy with me today.
But we'll create a fresh one.
We'll just choose PostgreSQL.
Pick an instance name.
And then I'm going to use a
really secure password here.
All right, so you can
choose any region you want.
So this is the regions that
we talked about earlier.
And then you can pick any zone.
I'm going to go ahead
and specify a zone,
for no particular reason.
In fact, we can pick any of
these zones and it's fine.
You can choose your version.
We just entered beta
for PostgreSQL 11.
So if you guys are interested
in that, you can check it out.
We can set our
connectivity, private IP,
public IP-- all of that.
We can change the size.
So if we decide we want
a little bit bigger,
we can scale that up.
We can even add extra
RAM if we need to.
We'll keep it pretty
small for right now.
And let's go down to
high availability.
So this is the high availability
feature we talked about.
This is going to make
sure that we always
have access to our data
with no involvement from me.
So I'm going to go ahead
and look everything over.
Great.
I'm going to go ahead
and create that.
OK.
So as you can see, right
now what's happening
is we're spinning
up the instance.
It usually takes like
four to five minutes
to spin up a Cloud SQL instance.
So it's not very long.
It's a lot faster than trying
to install PostgreSQL yourself--
or at least when I try to
install PostgreSQL myself.
Let's go ahead and go
back to the slides.
So while that's going, let's
move on to the next step
and talk about Kubernetes.
So how many people have
used Kubernetes here before?
Great.
Quite a few people.
So at Google, we run
everything in containers--
as much stuff as possible.
Gmail, web apps--
everything we can
runs in a container
on our infrastructure.
Even Google Cloud Platform
runs our VMs in containers.
So whenever you spin
up a compute instance,
that's actually a container.
And we launch several
billion containers per week.
Now, obviously, Google
has a lot of employees,
but not enough to hand-manage
several billion containers
a week.
That's a lot of
Docker runs to type.
So we came up with
something called Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is actually
based on something
we have internally.
It's open source.
It's written in Go.
And what it does is it
manages fleets of containers.
So what that means is that you
can essentially just tell it
what you want your
application to look like,
and Kubernetes will
make it happen.
It is based on our internal
system, which is called Borg.
We took a lot of the stuff we
learned when we created Borg,
and we brought it to Kubernetes.
It supports multiple
cloud environments.
You can run this
not just in GCP.
You can run it on Prem.
You can run it on
whatever cloud you want.
And it supports multiple
container runtimes.
So you're not
locked into anything
if you don't want to be.
So if you aren't
familiar with Kubernetes,
we're going to go through
just a few terms that we use,
specifically, one of them--
the first is, when it comes to
Kubernetes, you have clusters.
So a cluster is
a group of nodes.
And there's one master node.
So the master node
monitors the entire state
of all the other nodes.
And it updates the
environment as needed.
So it's going to take a look.
It's going to say,
hey, I'm supposed
to have three nodes here,
but I'm missing one,
or something's not working.
And it's going to
work to correct that.
So when we talk
about node, we're
talking about a single
machine in a cluster.
So we're going to
spin up a cluster.
It's going to have
three nodes in it.
And each node represents a
VM or a different machine
that we're running on.
And then last but not least,
we're going to talk about pods.
So a pod is one or
more containers.
So a pod is an atomical
unit in Kubernetes.
What it is, is it's an
instance of your application.
So you try to make the
pod as small as possible.
You represent one runtime
of your application.
And sometimes, you have
multiple containers,
which we'll talk about as well.
So if you use Google
Kubernetes Engine,
there's even a few
more advantages.
So you have auto repair.
If one of your nodes goes
down-- so one of your VMs
stops working for some reason,
whether it's something you did.
It's something the
VM just crashed.
Sometimes that happens.
We keep an eye on it.
And we automatically
repair that and replace it.
So your node could go down.
We'll put a new node
in your cluster.
And you won't even notice.
We have auto upgrade.
So you don't have to
worry about running
updates and stuff like that.
You can just click a button,
and it will automatically
roll you up to the most
recent version of GKE.
So if any of you
guys have ever tried
to manage a fleet
of your own servers,
that is a super time saver.
And last but not least,
we even have auto scaling.
We're going to talk a little
bit about pod auto scaling,
but this is node auto scaling.
So we can actually
add additional nodes
into your cluster.
If your cluster is not big
enough to handle the load
you're trying to, we can
throw in some extra VMs,
beef it up for a little while.
And then when the load subsides,
we can take those VMs back way.
And you only have to
pay for what you used.
OK.
So with all that in
line, let's go back
to the presentation--
or the computer
here-- and set up a GKE cluster.
All right, so I'm going to click
right here to create a cluster.
It's got a lot of
the same stuff.
We'd better just
match numbers, right?
We don't want to be wrong.
OK.
So we have a couple of
different location types.
We can either have our
cluster be in a zone,
or we can have it be regional.
So what happens when
we select a region is
we no longer can select a zone.
But instead, it's going
to create nodes inside
of each different region--
sorry-- each different zone.
So we're going to
have one region,
but the nodes are going to be
spread throughout the zone.
And we can also beef these
up a little, add some CPUs.
Great.
So what's happening here is
I selected one for number
of nodes, but it's per zone.
So I'm going to have
three nodes total,
and it's going to be spread
out between the zones.
OK.
And if any of you have ever
tried to start up Kubernetes
before, this is 100 times
faster than I've ever spun it up
on my own.
So I always love doing this,
because it's very fast.
So while it's
spinning up those VMs,
we'll go back to the
slides a little bit.
And then we'll come
back and take a look
these in a few minutes.
Can we go back to the
presentation, please?
Great.
OK.
So let's talk about
deploying the application.
Let's take a look
the infrastructure.
So we have a couple of different
components going on here.
It's a lot to take in,
but let's break it apart.
So the first thing we notice
is we have the end user.
The end user is going to be
interacting through a load
balancer.
The load balancer is
going to be distributing
all of the traffic
between the pods.
So we talked about
pods earlier--
that's an atomical unit.
The pods are inside
a deployment.
So we're going to
tell Kubernetes,
hey, we have a deployment.
The deployment is going
to manage the pods for us.
The load balancer is
going to direct traffic
to all of the pods.
And the pods are going to
connect to our Cloud SQL
instance, and our Cloud SQL
instance has high availability.
So it's got a
synchronous replication
to a standby instance.
If we take a look
inside the pods,
you can see we have two
different containers-- one's
our application, and one's
using the Cloud SQL proxy.
So this is what we call
the sidecar pattern.
So let's take a look inside
the application container.
So this is a file from
the actual deployment.
You're going to see it in
a second, when I deploy it.
You'll notice we're
using secrets.
So secrets are a
way that Kubernetes
can represent information.
You create a secret, and
it can interject those
into the pods as
environment variables.
This is a really good way
to pass along information.
So here we're passing
in information
about the database user
and the database password.
You can also see, if you
look on the top there,
we have the container port.
So it's listening on 8080.
This is just the
default for Flask.
And you can see
for image, that's
going to pull container
image front right from my GCR
repository.
We also have the sidecar.
So this is the sidecar.
It was an addition
to the main car.
And you can see this
is the Cloud SQL proxy.
This is an image we provide.
So you don't have to make
your own if you don't want to.
You can if you want.
It's open source.
You can just slap this on there.
It'll pull it down.
And then you're just going to
give it the command to start.
So we're specifying
the instance name,
the port we want
the proxy to listen
to, and then the credential
file for the service account.
That's all we have to do
to get it up and running.
We're using volume mounts
to pass this secret in.
So it's mounting the
file as a volume.
It's putting that volume
into the container.
And the container is accessing
it when it starts up.
So then we talked about
the load balancer.
The load balancer-- all we're
going to do is specify a name.
It's going to be called
tabs versus spaces.
We specify a type.
The whole thing is
called a service.
We specify the type of service.
The service is a load balancer.
And then the selector.
The selector is
going to determine
which pods it's pointing to.
So we're going to be using
app, tabs versus spaces.
That says grab all of
the pods with the label
tabs versus spaces
and start using those.
And then at the end,
we're specifying
what port we're listening on.
Now, just because my development
server listens on 8080
doesn't mean we want to here.
So I'm going to
listen on port 80.
I'm going to send that traffic
to my pods, which are listening
on port 8080 and with TCP.
OK.
So now let's walk through
deploying the application
and take a look at everything.
If we can switch back to
the presentation, please.
So now that we have
these up, let's go ahead
and take a look at what
exactly we have going on.
So this is the database
that we just created.
You can see here that
we see CPU utilization.
So this is an instance
of the database,
but we actually have to
create the database real
quick on here.
You can do things like you
can manage connections.
You can manage users.
All of that stuff
is provided here.
We've got backups, replications,
operations-- all that stuff.
I'm just going to create
a real quick database
for my application to
connect to and use.
OK.
So that is creating.
So now I can come over
here and do the same thing
with my GKE cluster.
I can take a look.
You can see the master version.
It has an endpoint.
So this is the
endpoint that I would
connect to the cluster itself.
We have a whole bunch
of other things in here.
There's a lot of information.
It's all in here.
You can take a look at any
persistent volumes, any nodes.
All of that stuff
is listed here.
What I want to do is connect.
So I'm going to go ahead and
click Connect right here.
It's going to give me a URL.
And I'm going to take this
and move over to Cloud Shell.
So if you guys haven't
used Cloud Shell before,
it's a really cool
thing that you get free
with the GCP account.
Essentially what it
is is the VM that's--
it's not persistent.
You keep your home
folder, but it launches up
with a click of a button.
So you can click it
and you can open it up.
You can see right here I
have the application open
in the background.
I haven't deployed it yet.
But just to show you guys
the code, it's very small.
It's one Python file.
It is 175 lines of code, and
most of that is comments.
So there's not a
lot going on there.
It's just going to connect
to the database for us.
And if we put this--
OK, so that is the
command to connect.
We're going to go
ahead and click that.
And it's going to
connect to our cluster.
OK, everybody read the
text OK, even in the back?
Good?
Awesome.
All right.
OK.
So now I can talk to my cluster.
Maybe.
OK.
No resources found.
That's to be expected.
Let's take a look
at the services.
So we should see at least
one, because Kubernetes itself
is a service.
OK.
We've got one.
So we're connected
to our cluster.
Everything's good.
So we talked a little
bit about secrets.
So let's take a look at
what the secrets looks like.
We just have in here
the database name.
Now these are encrypted.
But you saw on the [INAUDIBLE]
earlier, it's not very hard.
In case you forgot,
it's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
These are just encrypted.
You can either create
these via the command line,
or you can 64-bit encrypt
it and throw it in here,
and Kubernetes will take
care of it automatically.
So I'm going to
do kubectl create.
This is going to tell
Kubernetes to create the file.
And I want to start
with the secrets.
OK.
So there you go.
You can see at the bottom I
created two different secrets.
One is the credential file.
And the other one is the
secrets for connecting.
So that is the database
name, password, and username.
We can take a look
at the deployment.
So this is the deployment that
we talked about earlier, right?
Just to go over it all again.
We can see the name.
It's going to apply labels
to everything in here.
This is going to be how
our load balancer is
going to find it later.
For containers, we have
tabs versus spaces.
We have the gcr.io.
We have our secrets put in here.
So it's going to
use those secrets.
This is the sidecar, right?
So I know it's hard to
see because it's not very
big-- well, it is a big screen.
But it's not very big fonts.
So the only thing we need to do
is put the instance connection
name in here.
So if we come back
to our database,
we can go to the overview and
the instance connection name
is right here.
So the cool part of
this is I don't even
have to worry about--
with the proxy, I don't have to
worry about if I create a new
database, or-- sorry-- if I
change the IP address for some
reason-- like if I'm running
private IP and I switch VPCs--
the proxy will
automatically figure it out
and update for me.
So I'm going to go ahead
and create that right there.
OK.
So I'm going to
create the deployment.
So you can see the
deployment is now created.
So if we try and
find some pods again,
we should hopefully
see something.
OK.
So if we take a look there, we
have one pod that started up.
So that's our deployment.
Our deployment says,
hey, I'm supposed
to have this
application running.
It's supposed to have a pod.
That pod has two different
containers in it.
So if we look at the status, it
says it's container creating.
Usually the first time
a container creates,
it takes a little bit
longer because it's
got to pull those
images from the repo.
But we can keep updating this
to make sure it's good to go.
OK.
While we give that
a second, we're
going to go ahead and start
talking about the load
balancer.
So for the load balancer,
it's pretty simple--
exactly what I
had on the screen.
We're using a selector--
app, tabs versus spaces.
So select all the pods
with tabs versus spaces.
And we're going to
listen on port 80,
and we're going to send
that traffic to port 8080.
OK.
And that's all it took to
create the load balancer.
So it read that file in.
It deployed it.
Everything is good to go.
So let's go back and see if
our pods are up and running.
OK.
You can see the pod is running.
It's about a minute old.
It has both the
containers are up inside.
And everything should be
hopefully working correctly.
We're about to find out for
real though, so while that
is creating the load balancer,
let's come back in here
and look around.
So we already showed you what
the SQL instance looks like.
You have CPU
utilization right now.
Not a lot's going on.
We can come over here to
the Kubernetes Engine.
We can get out of this.
So we can see workloads.
So right here, we
have a deployment.
We have tabs versus spaces.
I can click it and take a look.
So far, I don't have
any CPU memory or disk.
It hasn't been
running long enough.
But after a little while
we should hopefully
start to see that kind of info.
Right.
Perfect.
So here we have
CPU, memory, disk.
So you can actually
monitor each application
and see what it looks like.
We can look down.
We see labels.
This has labels, app,
tabs versus spaces.
That's how our load balancer
is going to find it.
We can see down here,
these are revisions.
We have managed pods.
So these are all the pods.
And then we have
exposing as a service.
So this is actually our
load balancer right here.
We can look at services, too.
All right, we have an IP.
So let's click it and make
sure everything's working.
Awesome.
Our application's
up and running.
So I'm going to take
this IP address.
I'm going to bring it over here.
OK.
Now, you guys go ahead,
pull out your phones,
open up your laptops,
whatever you need.
Go to that IP address.
Make sure I'm telling
you the truth.
I'm not pulling any
wool over your eyes.
And let's see who can win
between tabs and spaces.
Has everybody got the IP OK?
Anybody still waiting?
OK.
So just to make
sure, let's check
and see how things are going.
OK.
It looks like it's
a pretty close vote.
Spaces is barely pulling ahead.
Good news for the tabs folks.
I don't check to see
if you voted twice,
so just start clicking.
All right, so let's
go ahead and go back
to the slide real quick.
OK.
So now that we've
deployed our application,
let's look at some of the
things that can go wrong
and what we can do to stop that.
We've already done a
lot just by deploying
with Cloud SQL and Kubernetes.
But let's look at
what else can happen.
So when we talk about
fault tolerance,
it's important to remember
it's not fault proof, right?
We don't want to try and make
sure that nothing can ever
go badly, ever.
That is a losing strategy.
You will never be able
to make that happen.
You're always going to have
some type of hardware failure,
or something that's
impossible to schedule around.
What you can do is have a backup
plan for handling failures,
so that if something does
go wrong, you react quickly,
and hopefully, without a
lot of man hours involved.
You don't want to focus
on eliminating the chance
to go down, focus on getting
back up as quickly as possible.
So let's talk about
application failures.
Now, this is like
170 lines of Python.
I'm not very good at Python,
so maybe I did something badly,
and somebody figures out
a way to make it crash.
What's going to happen?
So Kubernetes is
constantly monitoring this.
It's going to take a look
and say, hey, wait a minute.
There's supposed to
be a pod running,
and it's supposed to have
this application in it.
I don't see any pods.
It's going to start that
pod back up within seconds.
I can go in.
I can kill a pod.
Kubernetes is going to
bring it right back up.
High traffic.
So let's say that
my little pod wasn't
enough to handle all of the
500-plus people in this room.
If that were the case, we
have a feature we can do.
We can add a pod autoscaler.
It's going to add more pods
as the CPU usage increases.
So as more people begin to go
ahead and use the application,
Kubernetes is going to go, hey,
this one pod is not keeping up.
I need to throw
some more in there.
I don't have to do anything.
It's automatically
going to react.
It's going to scale up.
It's going to handle
that load for me.
OK.
How about
infrastructure failure?
So now we've talked
about a bunch of things
that can go wrong on my end.
What happens if an
entire zone goes down?
What happens if it wipes out?
I can't talk to
that node anymore.
I can't talk to my
Cloud SQL instance.
Well, we made a
bunch of decisions
earlier, when we decided
to deploy regionally,
that even if a zone goes down--
remember the zones are fault
tolerant in different ways.
So if one go zone goes down,
the others are still remaining.
So our Cloud SQL instance
is going to failover.
We're going to see it go
down for maybe a minute,
and it's going to come back up.
And our Cloud-- our
Kubernetes instance
is going to do the same thing.
It's going to look
in the cluster
and go, whoa, hold on a second.
There's supposed to be
a bunch of pods running.
I don't see anything.
We need to fix that.
Again, hands off.
I don't have to do anything.
So with that in mind,
let's take a second
and examine the fault tolerance.
Actually, let's look at the
vote real quick and see.
OK.
Somebody has automated tabs.
And as you can
clearly see, spaces
is not going to catch
up anytime soon.
All right.
OK.
So if we look, we've
got two pods running.
That pod seems to
be doing OK so far.
But we have this
load balancer here.
So what exactly is this
load balancer going to do?
It's pretty simple.
It's going to apply
to all the labels
where tabs versus spaces is.
So it's going to look at all the
pods with tabs versus spaces.
Oh, that's the load balancer.
I want the autoscaler, sorry.
Autoscaler.
So this is horizontal
pod autoscaler.
We have minReplicas right here.
So minReplicas says, hey,
I want at least two pods
running all the time.
So what that means is
that even if something
goes wrong in that
pod, there may
be a split second where
Kubernetes doesn't
realize that pod is down.
But as long as I have two, even
if something goes wrong in one,
the other one is
still up and running.
So even if we're waiting a
couple of seconds for a new pod
to come up and replace it,
I have that one, at least,
responding to requests.
I can also set a max, right?
So I want to make sure I
don't run too many pods.
If I only have three
nodes, too many pods
isn't going to
help me out either.
It's going to add
a lot of overhead.
So I want to limit that to 10.
So only have 10 pods.
Anywhere between 2
and 10 is perfect.
We can also look at the
target's CPU utilization.
So this is how Kubernetes
is deciding to scale.
This is a metric that-- you
can create your own metrics.
Kubernetes is really extensible.
This essentially
says, hey, I want
each pod to be about 50% load.
That's going to give
me a little leeway,
just in case the pod
spikes up in traffic.
It's going to go, hey,
this pod's way over 50%.
I'm going to throw
some more pods in there
to balance it out.
And then we just have some
API stuff right at the bottom
that you don't really
have to worry about.
So with that in mind, let's
deploy my auto balancer--
or my autoscaler.
OK.
So now it's creating
my autoscaler.
It takes it a little
bit to start up.
I can check the
status of it with HPA.
So this shows my--
HPA is the Horizontal
Pod Autoscaler.
It's going to show
its status right here.
Right now, I'm
unknown out of 50%.
So it's still trying to
initialize, get some things,
see what's going on.
We see minpods, 2; maxpods, 10.
So let's look and see if
our pods have changed.
I still only have one pod.
So the HPA is taking
its sweet time.
I see replicas one.
OK.
Sweet.
So now it's started
up a second pod.
It's only eight seconds old.
So it's still getting there.
But we've got our backup pod
in case something goes wrong.
So even if I were to
crash one of these--
SPEAKER 1: Any chance
you could bump that up?
KURTIS VAN GENT: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Not font size.
KURTIS VAN GENT: Is that better?
Is it still big enough
for everybody to read?
SPEAKER 2: It's not the font.
SPEAKER 3: They want it higher.
You should offset
the bottom line.
KURTIS VAN GENT: Oh.
I see.
Sorry.
I totally misunderstood.
SPEAKER 1: There you go.
KURTIS VAN GENT: Is that better?
All right.
Thank you.
I'll be here all day.
OK.
So I deleted that
pod, and now you
can't really notice,
because I took
too long to figure out what you
guys were trying to tell me.
So it's hard to tell, but
this pod was with the b7mv8.
And that pod is no longer here.
So let me do this one more time.
So if anybody is
still trying to vote--
which I'm sure the guy who
automated that tab script is--
he's probably not seeing
any dropped connections.
Maybe one or two,
if he's unlucky.
But as soon as that
pod gets dropped,
Kubernetes realizes it.
It stops directing traffic to
it and sends it the other way.
So if I go right back--
OK.
I've got two pods.
One's only 16 seconds old.
So the one that I killed
has already been replaced.
So let's check again.
All right, tabs
is really winning.
Somebody on spaces
is trying to keep up,
but tabs must just be better
at automating the votes.
OK.
So we also have that autoscaler.
So let me start up some traffic.
So I've created a
compute instance here.
I'm going to grab my IP
address if I can find it.
I'm going to grab
the IP address.
And you guys are just
not quite enough load.
So let's see what
would happen if we
had several thousand
people trying
to log into this all at once.
OK.
So what this is doing is it's
just sending a ton of requests.
It's using a tester called hey.
It's written in Go.
It's just sending
a ton of requests,
trying to max out that
as much as possible.
And we can even come
in here and monitor it.
So we can take a look at our
service, tabs versus spaces.
So you can see
right now, there's
a sharp upcrease in CPU usage.
That's because we're sending
it a lot more traffic
than we were.
But so far we still
just have the two pods.
OK.
So while that's
going, we're also
going to talk about
the database failover.
So it's going to take like
maybe 30 or 40 seconds
for Kubernetes to figure
out that it needs more pods.
The autoscaler is customizable.
We're just using the
default options right now,
so it plays a little
on the safe side.
We're going to
switch the database.
And there is a button
right here for failover.
So this is really
useful if you want
to test how your
application works.
You can click failover.
It's going to simulate
that failover process.
So it's essentially going
to crash your database
intentionally.
Your data will be fine, but
it will allow your application
to practice failing over.
So we're going to
click failover.
It wants to make sure
I'm really this crazy.
OK, great.
So now the application is
failing, and it's down.
So if I take a look--
it's not working, right?
Sorry.
The application is
working, but it's
getting an error because it
can't connect to the database.
So whoever is voting your app--
or your script just crashed.
And it's going to be
down for a little bit.
It's going to take
like 30 or 40 seconds.
And while we're waiting
for that to react,
let's go ahead in here
and really screw it up.
I'm going to delete
all of the pods.
So unfortunately, I
don't have the power
to bring a zone
down all on my own.
But I'm going to delete
all the pods, because it's
a similar situation, right?
I've already shown you
that I can delete a pod
and it's going to
come right back up.
Maybe.
OK.
Perfect.
So now it's deleting
all the pods.
You can actually see
it deleted four pods.
So the autoscaler
was working hard.
It kicked up some extra pods,
and now it's deleted those.
So if I take a look
inside Kubernetes--
if I refresh this--
OK.
You see here, I
actually caught one
of the pods that's in the
process of being switched out.
So we have four healthy
pods that have already
replaced the four that broke.
And we have one that's
crashed and running.
And hopefully, if we
take a look over here,
my database is back up,
and so is my application.
So you guys were watching me.
I wasn't doing anything.
Kubernetes took care
of that all on its own,
with a little help from
Cloud SQL on the back end.
Can we go back to
the presentation?
So that is examining
fault tolerance.
We have about 15
minutes left, so I'm
going to do some
questions at the end here.
If you guys are interested
in trying this yourself,
we have a code lab
that's available online.
All the code for a
similar application.
You can create your
own meme generator.
If the only thing that's
different between tabs
versus spaces,
it's making memes.
So you can go to
this link right here,
GitHub.com/Googl
eCloudPlatform/gmemegen.
It's a hands-on,
step-by-step tutorial.
It does exactly
what I just did now,
so you can go home and
try it out yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]